cell injury is a kind of stress that  cell has to suffer due to external as  well as internal environmental changes  the organelles that are mostly affected  are mitochondria ER nucleus and the  membrane but what really causes cell  injury there could be physical damage  like trauma radiation heat Etc there  could be hypoxia which might be  resulting due to anemia ishimia  cardiopulmonary failure or even  co-poisoning there could be immune  reaction mediated damage that happens  for example in viral infection there  could be genetic disorders that leads to  cell injury also there could be  infections of virus parasites bacteria  which leads to cell injury and lastly  there could be nutritional imbalance  which leads to cell injury subscribe for  more